Since z equals the original value minus the mean, divided by standard deviation.
In other words, the number of standard deviations that the original value is
from the mean. Then a negative z score means that, the mean is greater than x.
That must mean that x is somewhere down here. So that doesn't necessarily mean
that the original value is negative, though it could be. It does mean that the
original value is less than the mean. The original value is less than zero, it
basically says the same thing as this first one, that the original value is
negative. In this one, the original value x minus the mean is negative, must
also be true. Because for the z score to be negative, then this is going to be
negative, because the standard deviation is always positive. Just to review,
remember when we calculated standard deviation, we squared all the deviations.
So all the deviations are then positive, because if you square anything negative
or positive, you get a positive number. And then we just took the average
squared deviation, which is still positive, and then we took the square root,
which is still positive. So remember that this standard deviation will always be
positive. Which means that if the z score is negative, then this numerator must
be negative. And that must mean that x is less than mu.